libs of tick tock one of our favorite
accounts on twitter has video of a first
grade teacher indoctrinating kids
in kindergarten through second grade
classrooms into transgenderism
so something that's really cool and
unique about who i am is that i am
transgender
so we touched a little bit about that at
the beginning of this week uh in the
book that miss hammond read but i'm
gonna give you my explanation about what
it means to be transgender as well so
when babies are born the doctor looks at
them and they make a guess about whether
the baby is a boy or a girl based on
what they look like and most of the time
that guess is 100 correct there are no
issues whatsoever
and but sometimes the doctor is wrong
the doctor makes an incorrect guess
when the doctor makes a correct test
that's when a person is called cisgender
when a doctor's guess is wrong that's
when they are transgender so
i'm a man but when i was a baby the
doctors told my parents i was a girl
and so my parents gave me a name that
girls typically have and bought me
clothes that girls typically wear
and until i was 18 years old everyone
thought i was a girl and this was super
super uncomfortable for me because i
knew that wasn't right
this is all obviously abusive this is
very confusing for children it's harming
their education this
girl i get i guess he's a woman she's a
woman it's very confusing she says i was
born a woman but now i'm a man
or i was born a man but the doctors made
their best guess and then thought that i
was a woman because i've got all the
female body parts and i'm obviously a
woman so this woman is extremely
confused and should not be allowed
within 100 yards of children and should
certainly not be teaching any children
the issue here is that nothing she said
is true
she is spouting delusional madness
when you walk past derelicts on the
street who are on drugs or who have all
sorts of mental problems and they're
just spouting nonsense and they're
talking to the air and they they are
talking to the multiple personalities
floating around them that only they can
see that you can't see
those people make more sense than this
woman
it's just completely wrong
it's especially wrong to confuse little
kids like this especially over an issue
that could have such horrible effects on
them they could end up mutilating
themselves they could end up
not knowing their very basic identity
and basic facts about the world
but it's just wrong it's not making
anyone happier
do you think that that woman is
stable happy
ready to go okay that's all i had to do
was pump myself full of hormones and
maybe undergo some
mutilations i don't know what and now
i'm really happy and well adjusted no of
course not and i
i don't really believe any statistics
that i read but such that we have
statistics none of this stuff is working
the argument from the the white house
and from the democrats right now is that
gender affirming counseling and drugs
and health care is really helping these
children deal with their stress and
anxiety it's not true you look at any
social scientific evidence the numbers
are getting worse since we began
indulging this crap five six seven years
ago
the rates of
suicide depression anxiety have gone up
they've especially gone up in kids
they've especially gone up in kids who
consider themselves lgbt lmnop so
whatever we're doing it's not working
it's having the opposite effect
and what are we doing the strategy is
affirm the delusions
and what is the consequence i know that
correlation is not necessarily causation
but i think there might be a link here
when we indulge delusion when we live in
fantasy world everything gets worse
nothing gets
better
people are really struggling so what's
what's the answer
let's try something different let's try
maybe the opposite approach
and these people who are pushing is
extraordinarily harmful and destructive
and false ideologies
they need to be put away
from the first grade classroom they need
to be put away from positions of
influence they need to get better and
they need to be brought into accord with
reality it's i'm not just focusing on
this one issue of transgenderism which
is no longer can you even really call it
a minor issue because it's exploding
right now in the public square
it's catching on like a social contagion
i'm talking about so many other issues
people are getting more anxious more
stressed more lonely more miserable and
so whatever we're doing we need to turn
it around
right now go to a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
michael
you know we predict the future on this
show well we told you months ago if
you're investing if you're investing in
crypto do it in a tax advantaged way
with alto crypto ira
well i i hope you took my advice on it
then because inflation is going through
the roof the value of our dollar is
plummeting if you haven't done it it's
not too late even if you're dabbling in
crypto don't just pay needless money to
the government in taxes go do this in a
tax advantaged way the best way to do
that is altos crypto ira will save you
the tax headache you can trade all that
you want you can get started by
investing with as little as ten dollars
and there are no setup fees there are 80
coins of it more than 80 coins available
actually we're talking bitcoin we're
talking ethereum we're talking cardano
do you want some sushi swap with your
bitcoin well you can do that no problem
alto ira has you covered open an alto
crypto ira account with as little as 10
bucks go to alto ira dot com slash
michael a-l-t-o-i-r-a dot com slash
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
start investing in cryptocurrency today
altoira.com
michael
i'm glad you liked that clip now i'm
just i'm going to make it very simple
ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications check out the other videos
you can also get the audio podcast on
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play at the michael knowles show leave a
five star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]